good nice to see you U.S President Joe
Biden met with his Mexican counterpart
Andre Manuel Lopez orador at the
presidential Palace in Mexico City
it's his first trip to Latin America
since entering the White House
the two leaders held a bilateral meeting
to discuss some of the pressing issues
affecting both Nations and to improve
relations that were strained by Mr
Biden's predecessor Donald Trump
President Biden you have the key to
significantly open and improve relations
between all countries of the American
continent
on Tuesday Mexico the U.S and Canada
will discuss important issues ranging
from economic cooperation and climate
change to Illegal migration and drug
trafficking
Biden arrived a few days after the
Detention of a video Woman the son of
the drug lord known as El Chapo who is
currently detained in an American prison
experts say the U.S is likely to ask
Mexico to do much more to stop the
trafficking of illegal drugs such as
fentanyl that killed thousands of
Americans each year but analy say
fighting the flow of drugs into the U.S
won't be seen a fentanyl being the theme
of the day as it were basically the
pressing domestic political issue in the
U.S as well more southern Mexico
is that so far everything seems to
indicate that we're repeating the same
mistakes that have been repeated in the
past we're still relying on the same
vocabulary the same practices of trying
to curb the flow of illicit drugs from
Mexico from Latin America more widely
speaking into the United States and
other parts of the western world
yeah no no no no no no another key issue
on the agenda is migration hundreds of
thousands of people are trying to reach
North America every year last week
President Biden announced a parole
program to allow 30 000 people from
Haiti Cuba Venezuela Nicaragua to enter
the U.S legally every month
and Mexico has said it will accept 30
000 deputies from the U.S each month
over 2 million people were detained
trying to cross the U.S Mexico border in
2022. human rightscripts have been very
critical with North American countries
migration policies that they say make it
difficult for Asylum Seekers to find
safety but leaders in the region are
also Under Pressure to find Solutions
many hope that New Alternatives will be
discussed during this meeting that will
not only criminalize migrants but help
them in a path to a better life
so let's get more on this now with Kurt
Hackbarth he's a writer and a journalist
and joins us live from Oaxaca in Mexico
Kurt good to have you with us so look I
mean President Biden's agenda seems to
be more focused on domestic issues like
migration border security drugs like
fentanyl how does that fit in with the
Mexican president's more broader
Continental views and objectives at this
Summit
yeah and thanks for having me tonight
um I think that's absolutely right
um
part of the frustration that Mexico
often has with these Summits is that the
United States uh comes with an agenda
tailored to its own political or
electrical or domestic needs so you see
the United States talking about
migration about drugs about security
which are all of course important issues
but what Lopez obrador is I think
inviting the United States to do is to
kind of broaden its view and broaden its
approach so shortly before the summit uh
Lopez sent Biden a letter saying look
this is what we want to talk about we
want to talk about integrating the
continent we want to talk about
producing what is needed in North and
South America here instead of importing
from Asia we want to talk about
combating inequality we want to talk
about the United States respecting the
sovereignty of Latin American nations
all of this by way of saying that
implicitly the United States causes a
lot of the same problems that then you
know complains about so let's start
attacking the sources of these problems
let's talk about migration curve because
human rights groups have been critical
of Biden's migration policy they say
look it makes it very difficult for
Asylum Seekers to find safety so given
just the the sheer numbers of migrants
trying to cross into the U.S where can
both men find Common Ground here do you
think
it's actually interesting that migration
appears to be one of the issues where
there is going to be common ground uh
tomorrow
um unfortunately Biden has continued a
lot of the Trump era policies on
migration and it was just saying that
the just last week he's talked about
turning the screws more uh by turning
away Venezuelans Cuban Haitians you know
and uh and uh and nicaraguans there the
problem is is that um
the idea that you can't
um
ask for immigration ask for Asylum until
you get to
[Music]
um
you have to ask for asylum on the way up
is a problem right now Mexico has agreed
to take on thousands of um of
of people from these countries so Mexico
is doing an enormous uh service here
that I think doesn't get
um the attention its needs in them in
the United States this is going to be an
ongoing problem specifically until the
united states recognizes that inequality
um that's
problems in these home countries our
companies migration migratory problems
and it's not going to go away just a
quick thought on trade Kurt um Lopez
Labradors complained you touched a
little while ago that too many Imports
are coming in from Asia instead of being
made in the Americas would you agree
with that and what's the way forward
just very quickly
yes very quickly
um amlo's point is that what's
produced can be
produced a lot of
uh and we see now with the near soaring
of um of companies here into Mexico uh
near the near the U.S border that
there could be a lot more economic
integration amongst the three countries
and this is interesting precisely at a
time when tensions are rising uh between
the United States and China almost
looking for an opening for more economic
integration there saying look this is
something that we can do in the Americas
and this is something that structurally
will help things like migration and
insecurity by providing these kind of
jobs here close by all right cut but
really good to get your thoughts indeed
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us Kurt thank you
thank you